R plus 6 s divided by r plus s is correct. That's some amazing work with
rationals if you're getting it right. You might have been stumped on how to
factor one of these. If so, watch me do the first one, and then see if you can
finish tackling this problem. To divide by any fraction, including a rational
expression, we change division to multiplication and multiply by their
reciprocal of the first fraction. Now we want to start factoring each piece of
these fractions. I'm going to start with this first one. We know the first two
terms must be r since r times r is r squared. Now we're just trying to find
factors of negative 12 that sum to positive 1. Since there's a 1 in front of
this r times s. We know that positive 4 and negative 3 multiplied together is
negative 12, and sum to give us positive 1, but notice that I need a negative 12
s squared for my last term. This must mean that I need a variable of s after
each of these numbers. We can quickly check this factoring by multiplying out
the binomials in our head. R times r is r squared, and 4s times negative 3s is
negative 12s squared. This positive 1 r s comes from multiplying these two terms
together, and adding it to the result of multiplying these two together. So we
have negative 3 r s plus 4 r s, which is 1 r s. For this first denominator, we
want to find factors of negative 20 that sum to negative 1. For our second
fraction we want to find factors of negative 30 that sum to 1. That would be
positive 6 and negative 5. And then for our denominator of our second fraction
we want to find factors of negative 3 that sum to negative 2 which are negative
3 and positive 1. Now that everything's factored let's cancel our terms in the
numerator and denominator. There, r minus 3 s divided by r minus 3 s equals 1.
And r plus 4 s divided by r plus 4 s also equals 1. The last factor we need to
cancel is r minus 5 s. And this leaves us with our final answer, r plus 6 s
divided by r plus 1 s, or just s.